lots of this paper relates to partition
and networks some of you may have seen
me present some other work in the same
domain I have a sequence of papers a
couple years back in a similar networks
meeting I talked about
um private conversation in networks
where we can send different signals to
different agents today I'm going to talk
about a newer paper where we focus on
public signals and using public signals
to influence agents decisions in network
systems
um Okay so
let's let's start with the
um very simple
um description of the model and I'm
going to basically solve this model in
some detail in the remainder of two of
today's talk so I'll think about a fixed
Network and agents will take binary
actions in this network and
um I'm going to focus on a setting with
a setting where agents actions exhibit
strategic complementarities so focus on
this payoff function in particular T is
the state of the word that's a Priory
unknown
now um
I'm going to think about the problem of
a information designer who chooses a
mechanism that Maps the state to some
signals informative about the underlying
state of the world with the objective of
influencing the agent's actions and
maximizing a certain objective in
today's talk I'll focus on the objective
of maximizing the total number of agents
who take action remember I mean a binary
action setup
um so if you want to think about an
application we can think about the
following how can I design public
signaling mechanisms so as to influence
agents purchase decisions where I'm
interpreting the zero one action is
purchasing a product versus that and
it's a setting with network
externalities agents derive higher value
from consuming the same product as their
peers and the state may take post or
negative values
representing lower high quality and if
the if state is negative the quality is
low maybe I do not want to purchase the
product I I get some this utility from
that in a setting how should I decide on
my mechanism how should I reveal
information about the underlying state
so as to maximize the total sales that
will be the question that I'm asking
um okay in this setting there are a
number of different questions that I
would like to address number one what
are doctoral information structures how
do they depend number two how they
depend on the network structures what if
I do not know the entire network but I
have some some summary statistics
available to me and um can I really
think about what types of networks are
more amenable to persuasion might that's
what I mean is that are there Network
structures where by designing
appropriate information structures the
designer can guarantee higher payo for
herself versus slower right so these are
the questions that I would like to
address
right so here's a brief overview of
what's going to come in the remainder of
the talk I will argue that and this is
not a particular difficulty result I'll
show that the optimal public signals can
be characterized in terms of the course
of the underlying graph
um I'll Define this later on in case
you're not familiar with course the set
of indopto mechanism the set of possible
signal realizations will correspond to
the set of distinct cores of the
underlying Network and basically the
mechanism will have the form where um
when the is when the mechanism then the
signal realization is K agents in the k
core of the underlying network will end
up taking action one
um there will be some interesting
structure to the optimal mechanism which
I'll refer to as the double interval
structure throughout the talk uh
basically uh the structure is as follows
I'll have one dimensional States
um I'll Define it uh I'll introduce some
notation later on but get this
horizontal by represent possible State
realizations the design is going to
obtain a partition of that state space
and with each possible signal
realization the designer will associate
at most two sub-intervals of the state
space so for instance when the state
realization is here or here the signal
realization is green and agents in a
corresponding core will end up taking
action one so this
um double interval structure will be uh
we will pin down the optimal mechanism
um in in basically all problem instances
that I'll focus on
um we will have a simple convex program
plus an algorithm to derive the optimal
information structures and um I should
also note that after writing this paper
um in a subsequent work with Phillips
track we actually generalized the
results here quite a bit that paper does
not focus on networks but really in a
much richer setting where our agents
have private information one can think
about the optimal information structures
in a in in in
partitions that generalize the winter
structure turn out to be optimal in my
future settings time permitting I'll
briefly comment on that
um we also I'll also illustrate that um
one can open a synthetically optimal
mechanisms for
um large random networks basically by
knowing only the limiting degree
distribution and um to answer that
question about what type of metrics are
more more amenable to persuasion
um I'll focus on degrees degree
assertivity and I'll argue that degree
assertive certainty makes networks more
amenable to persuish
um so that's the plan for um for the
rest of the talk briefly about the
related literature I'm building on two
long lines of work on one hand I have
the patient Precision information design
literature on the other hand I have
games on network literature there are
many papers in the games literature that
really think about how we can design
transfers to induce desired outcomes in
Network games here as opposed to using
transfers I'll be using information to
induce desired outcomes in the setting
one can think about different
information structures I can think about
sending private signals to agents that's
what I did in my earlier work with Kim
Andrea kaplos of USC in today's paper
I'll be thinking about public signals
that all agents observe the same signal
realization
and um I'll try to shed light on this
interplay between the network structure
and open information structures
um so please let me know if you have any
questions this was very high level
overview now I I plan to go down to the
details and tell you about the model and
the results a little bit a little bit
more forward
so um here we go I'm going to think
about uh unrelated social network waited
for based version of the problem it
needs a similar solution so throughout
the talk just assume that my GI jsr01
depending on whether I have an edge
between agents inj
um each agent takes a binary action this
is the payoff structure if I take action
zero my payoff is normalized to zero if
I take action one it is State plus a
network external term
um the state is distributed with respect
to some distribution F and I'm going to
assume that the state space is
continuous
um it's a sub interval of the reals it's
one dimensional and I'm going to make
some assumptions on F just to simplify X
position a little bit I'm going to
assume that it's a continuous
distribution if I had discrete
distribution solution would be similar
but I would have to worry about
randomization and whatnot and I don't
want to go there
and the key thing here is that agents
take actions before observing the states
so in the absence of any information
they will take action so as to maximize
their expected payoffs and my question
is the following suppose that a designer
an information designer committed to a
public signaling mechanism which mapped
uh the signal the state realization to
different signal realizations this could
be something like choosing a threshold
and revealing whether the state
realizations below or about that
threshold or it could be fully revealing
the state or something in between
um or remember the partition structures
that I mentioned earlier that would be
another example of a information
structure that turns out to go so the
question is how should I choose my
um uh mechanism so as to maximize this
quantity total number of agents that
take action
um in the absence of any information
agents would just take action so it's to
maximize their expected payoffs written
here if I publicly reveal some signal
agents would update their posterior of
the state and take possible different
actions really the name of the game is
how should I choose that mapping G
um I guess I didn't introduce notation
here how should I choose this public
signaling mechanism so as to maximize
this quantity that was a question uh why
did you take the expectation inside the
AIS uh AI is not a linear function right
so
wouldn't the agent want to maximize the
expectation of a i of t plus
so people take the expectation outside
and oh I say so you are saying that I
don't just write the expected uh payoff
um
what's that so AI is not a function so
it's AI is a constant uh yeah
so this was meant to illustrate the
setting where agents do not observe any
information if I don't have any
information I just take my actions if I
observe a similarization s i update the
posterior and take actions in the letter
setting I should have written a as a
function of s the signal that's observed
by agents but all ages observe the same
signal here so I'm just taking a
shortcut
foreign
structure
multiplicity of equilibrium
so good
um let me actually tell you exactly what
I'm going to do and now let me tell you
what would happen if I focus on
different things
um now given the uh mechanism of the
designer agents effectively given the
signal realization agents effectively
play the super modular game that I have
written here it has the largest
equilibrium and a small st equilibrium
and I will always be breaking ties in
favor of the designer I'll always focus
on the equilibrium that deals the
highest paid to the uh to the to the to
the designer in other words I'll I will
always be looking at the largest
equilibrium of this super modular game
um and this is what uh corresponds to
the course of the underlying Network
um so what's the k-core I'm sure some of
you are familiar with that in case you
are not k-core is the maximal induced
sub graph where all nodes have degree uh
K or larger that's a mouthful just
thinking about the following in future
procedure I give you a network and I'm
just going to remove nodes from that
Network
um whenever I um I find the node that
has degree less than K and I continue
doing that iteratively at the end of
today I'm going to converge a sub
Network that is going to be the k core
of Minecraft note that it's different
than the set of all nodes that have
degree K or larger because it could be
the it could be the case that there is a
node that has degree K but it has bunch
of low degree neighbors so when I'm
Computing the core I iteratively remove
those neighbors and I end up removing
this Central node as well simply because
at the end of this procedure it is left
without K neighbors who who belong to
the same subgraph
um what is that relevant quantity
suppose that the I reveal my public
signal the posterior mean all agents
share the same posterior mean here
posterior mean is let's say minus five
if I have a group of agents who have
degree five or more for this group of
agents to network externalities are
going to outweigh the districtility due
to low state so it's it is an
equilibrium for all these agents to take
action one and that can't be a larger
group of agents who take action one
because if I had a larger group then if
this one of these agents would have
degree less than five in my example and
for that agent it will be optimal not to
take action one so this is why Sunday
prefer the equilibrium character as in
terms of the course of down the
Minecraft
um what would happen if I were to focus
on let's say the smallest equilibrium of
uh of of of of this game it turns out
that not much would have changed of
course the relevant project object would
not be the core but when I say not much
not much would have changed but I mean
is that the structural properties of
double interval structure Etc would
effectively remain intact there's one
big issue that pops up and you look at
the lowest equilibrium and it is that as
a function of the posterior mean the
designer's payoff or the set of Agents
or the cardinality of set of Agents will
take action one is no longer upper semic
continuous it is lower same continuous
which means that in the designer's
problem the Supreme may not be achieved
but you can of course guarantee near
optimality um with an appropriate
perturbation of the picks so um
structurally not much changes then I
focus on the smallest as opposed to the
largest state group so gnhas are zero
one or we can take
um they are zero one I could allow for
weighted uh
the wooden shake or change that yeah it
would be a generalized
yeah so there's another notion of core
that generalizes the SE okay courses I
defined so basically if you have the
weights duration of the payoff star
you'll develop that version
so have you thought about the
customization version of the problem
where I basically you have like a
super sub-motional thing
sorry customization so let's define
interpreter utilities as costs and
you're minimizing
um
so short answers I don't talk about uh
the version that you did in mind but I
um why don't we talk about what exactly
what to get their title to talk okay
um so what my objective here is just to
illustrate
um
um for this
um super motion appealth structure the
optimal information structures but um as
I I mentioned earlier the subsequence
worked where I uh focus on settings way
more General than the preparation
settings here turns out that some
mathematical properties that I'm
leveraging that practice of two
information structures are quite
prevalent it does not restricted build
to display of structure so it's going to
be the case that the cost minimization
version of the problem that you have in
mind can also be addressed using the
same tools and similar structural
properties
but let's talk about the tail system
over here
um
okay I guess I already mentioned that
um in an equilibrium the set of agents
who take action one jointly will
correspond to a core of the network
um this means that I can write an
optimal mechanism by just restricting
attached to a close-off mechanisms where
the singularizations correspond to
different cores when the signal
realization is K the agents in the k
core end up taking action one joint of
course there's still the equation of how
that Design This mechanism and let me
give you a kind of a caricature of how I
think about this question
so I hit my state space again it's one
dimensional
um and really I'm trying to assign
different states to a different course
I'm trying to to to to persuade motivate
different groups of agents to take
action one for different state
realizations really my problem is
effectively a partitioning problem I
take the state space and I partition it
to different partition elements red
partition element yellow green and so on
and so forth when the state realization
belongs to the red partition elements I
probably could say red and ages in a
certain chord take action one when it is
green a different group of Agents take
action one you know the question is how
should I be choosing my partitions so as
to maximize the designer's payoff that I
described earlier now let me denote by
Arcade the cardinality of the k core I
can mathematically write this question
as follows I'm I'm solving over the
partitions of the state space such that
when the state below to the Kate
partition element the expected payoff of
the agents in the k-core is not negative
so they find welcome to take action one
this is what this constraint says and I
would like to ensure that
I maximize this payoff which is the
expected number of agents who take
action one given my partitions
our case are the cardinalities of the
course
now um
okay this is a problem that I can write
but I don't know how to solve this
problem given that the set of partitions
is quite Rich here right so I don't know
how to directly optimize our partitions
at this point I don't I don't know any
structural properties of these
partitions
I'm going to do something
slightly different and it's um
if you think about this for a minute it
becomes a little bit obvious that
there's this alternative approach that
you can take
I am in a setting where the agent's
payoffs are cosilinear in the state so
the object that really matters is the
posterior mean distribution that I
induce by choosing the partition of the
state space
so as opposed to optimizing our
partitions directly let me think in
terms of the posterior mean
distributions that's what I am going to
do
um all right
so
let's go back to Blackwell for a second
I have a prior distribution I'm asking
myself how you know what are the
posterior mean distributions so I can
induce given that prior distribution
turns out that this question is a pretty
elegant answer and it is characterized
in terms of this set of constraints
um sometimes they are referred to as NPC
in preservical traction constraints
sometimes in the literature you'll see
people referring to them as majorization
constraints in a nutshell this is what
the constraint says suppose that I had a
prior distribution F and I can choose a
signal to induce the posterior mean
distribution G if and only if this
condition holds I'm integrating my CDF
and for any point in the support
Omega this inequality should hold and at
the lowest point of the support
inequality should hold its equality
um now I have a you know I have a
Continuum of uh states you have a family
of constraints you have an infant family
of constraints so that still is not um
there is it still doesn't lead me to a
very easy formulation right I'm now
trying to optimize our distributions
that satisfy this infinite family of
constraints however oh I have timings
okay however
um
okay
um uh
this way so um
I think so as well it is an 18 minutes
since I started
but
okay so how much do I have eternal today
22 minutes okay thank you
I feel like I I won the lottery now
all right um let me go back to here
so okay it still looks like I'd be proud
to solve but
remember I'm in a setting where I'm
really choosing a distribution to
activate different cores it suffices to
really think about discrete
distributions G so really I could write
an optimization problem over the
locations of different Mass points as
well as the probabilities that I
assigned to them right I could think
about if there are M different scores I
could choose a triple PK and PK MK for K
ranging from 1 to M right the
probability of each Mass point and the
location of each Mass point and I could
optimize over discrete distributions
parameterized by these quantity satisfy
my inequality
um you could do that that would lead to
a finite formulation that is non-convex
but with a slight change of variables it
turns out that one can express the
condition here in terms of the convex
set of constraints that I have at the
bottom of the slide what is MK MK
um over here would be the location of
the Kate Mass Point PK is the
probability of that mass point and as
opposed to working on that parameterized
space I'm transforming my variables and
solving it into Z key zkp
space the reasons that when I do that
variable transformation and that with a
simple convex program versus the mkbk
formation that would be an outcome mix
program
okay so there's some stability there
that it turns out that this trick allows
me to simplify the problem quite a bit
um
okay so when I put everything together
the partitioning problem takes a much
simpler form now I'm going to as opposed
to solving our uh over partitions I'm
just going to solve this convex program
of course I still need to think about
how to recover the optimal mechanism
given the optimal distribution
parameters in terms of my businesses
um but I'll take a two-step approach let
me
um think about the solution to this
program first and then let me reason
about how to recover a partition that
induces the correct optimal distribution
so that's kind of the approach I'm going
to take
um okay so the main struct yes
I'm writing it's um it is an upper bound
but it turns out to be a tight upper
bound so exactly
exactly
that was another question was the same
question
uh-huh
right so um
good
um yes the formulation will change I do
not have a finite formulation like this
type in particular is the posterior mean
changes the ingredients consumption
quantity is going to change
um so I will end up with not the finite
uh problem like the one here but the
international problem I can discretize
and try to solve it to near optimal to
using the same tricks that I'm
introducing here
any other questions
so main structural property the double
interval started image in the beginning
here's what it looks like um in a
picture
um this is an example where my state is
uniformly distributed between 0 and
minus 50. I have an underlying network
with about four thousand nodes what you
see here colored in different colors are
not the course of the network because
you know 10 core and fifth core of the
network are not disjoint they overlap
but it is what is fantastic word is the
shellsoft network or the set of net mode
that multiple k core but not the K plus
your score
um so I use I think network is an input
I compute the cardinalities of different
cores I solve the optimization problem
that I mentioned earlier and then I
obtained a partition that induces the
correct distribution which looks like
what what you see over here and just
like what I motivated in the very
beginning
um in this partition
um with some signal realizations I
associate
um multiple I associate two cell
intervals of the state space so when the
state is in this or that interval I send
a signal that induces the third of
course 31st chord to take action one and
um for the orange signal I had to study
internal sensor similar for the blue and
for the rest I had a single second term
now
how they obtain a partition like that
and why should we believe that double
internal structure is the right
structure to uh folks
let me use some um infusion okay I don't
I just missing something basically so do
you when you say double interval
structure you just
how many they're look they're more than
two intervals there right with each
signalization I associate up to two sub
internals of the state space I see
that's what I mean when I say double
construct there's some other technical
structure but I think about digest
described captures uh the name uh
any other business
Okay so
um why not
you know how can I restrict attention to
just saying through some in terms of the
state space final time it's something
richer why is it not so efficient to
assign a single second circle of the
state space to each core or each signal
realization well here's a intuitive
picture suppose that I have this
partition at the bottom red and blue
right
well I can always do the following I can
take the middle segment
and shoot some of the protein Mass to
left and the rest right and end up with
another distribution
that
um in which the red and blue signal says
the same probability and the conditional
mean is exactly the same right so there
is no reason to go to you know three um
two to two partitions where some signals
are assigned to three sub intervals of
the state space
except that's what I said is not 100
correct and maybe Walmart is going to
point that
I don't ask a question and then I'll
continue
yeah so uh basically
I'm going to so let me just tell you
this and then get back to the connection
um
I I mentioned uh before the question
that what I described is not 100
accurate because this intuition that I
presented doesn't really work if you
have a partition like this one I cannot
uh send part of the red mass in the
middle to left and right and preserve
the uh the the the posterior mean
distribution and
um well it kind of it turns out that a
technical Lemma can be used to rule out
to some rule out the optimality of such
partitions basically it suffices to take
a partition of the state space such that
within each sub interval within each
partition element
um the posterior mean distribution has
up to two atoms and a 10 points the the
MPC constraints are binding so that
actually allows one to simplify the
problem to sub intervals of the state
space where within each sub-interval you
have at most two atoms and then this
intuition turns out to be correct so
that that would be a connection to
Phillips on their paper
um other questions
good
um
and this should be obvious for many who
worked on information design but
um just in case you know this area is
new to you
um why why does it not suffice to focus
on information structures that I assign
a single sub interval of the state space
to each signal realization suppose that
I have a pale structure that looks like
this one and I restrict attention to
assigning a single sub interval of the
state space to each signal realization I
would end up with something like a
disparation here as the optimal
partition within the class of monotone
partitions that I described
um here when the state belongs to this
left hand my payoff is zero and the
mutual thing that you would want to do
is to try to increase your payoff here
how would you do that maybe you can
start sending sending the green signal
here but if you were to do that your
posterior mean gets lower so your payoff
drops you don't want to do that somehow
you want to preserve the the um the
posterior mean when the green signal is
sent what you can do is to basically
extend the screen region and mix some of
the high States together so that when I
send the green signal the posterior mean
is still here with the blue signal it is
over here and um your payoff for as long
as iron and R2 are close to each other
and R3 is lower your payoff will be
higher so in a nutshell What's Happening
Here is that by pulling the low States
and high States appropriately we are
expanding the set of posterior means
that are implementable
um
let's see I
um 15 minutes is that okay
um so this is just yes
do you have a sufficient condition on
the neck
so that will guarantee that um
that would be nice but I do not
um
and you know in various examples that I
tried like for some random networks and
what but I ended up uh with structures
that are not monotone partitions so
while I'm not a formal statement I do
not expect the optimality to optimality
of the monotone partitions to be a
um generalized
um yes regarding the opposite direction
um
so you have a specific
payoff structure here as a function of
the expected means
you know because you know increasing
that this is okay cut points there
if you didn't have the structure it was
a general information design problem
where you care only about the expected
meaning
here would you also get the optimality
of the
I would
so what your song is yes so this is
related to networks
so good so the particular structure that
is derived like the particular pale
structure in the background
um is a function of the underlying
Network
um but the optimality of the double
intervals I think I may have it in the
next slide is going to be actually uh
true more generally through general
information design but
um good yes and um there will be some
results related to the network structure
around networks that are coming up in a
second of course they will be special
only to our network settings
Network externality so that you can
actually characterize the equation using
the cable function or that's I do but I
think the question is that suppose that
we didn't have that structure right um
it's a fraction of the posterior I mean
your payoff is going to be let's say
another step function not necessarily
even an increasing step function right
with the level interval structure
structure yield optimal mechanism in
that case the answer is yes and actually
let me say that that's affirmative there
and also build on that to tell you how
how much further one can push that
result
um if it is if you do not tell us the
function there may be also regimes where
um you fully reveal the state foreign
you'll have intervals you'll have the
sub in terms of State space where you
activate the double internal structure
outside these the prior and the
posterior mean would match which means
that there there will be sub internal
internal total State space very fully
revealed State and other sub intervals
where we have the partition structure
the time scratch so that's why I made
that decision
um very good so going back to Omar's
question here
um basically What's Happening Here is
that the uh because of the technical
Lemma that I alluded to earlier the
optimal posterior distribution is such
that there are some intervals of the
state space at the endpoints of this sub
intervals the MPC constraints are
binding and within those sub intervals I
have at most two atoms that's a
byproduct of the optimality conditions
in the problem that I posted earlier
because of that the designers problem
decouples over different sub internals
of the state space and in each sub
interval I need to basically induce two
atoms correctly well then I have a sub
internal State space and I need to
assign some of these states to a red
signal the rest to a green signal you
can solve in terms of the end points of
the Interior interval
match the correct distribution and then
um you know the uh the the complement of
that interval would induce the second
atom within the same interval so if you
start thinking about it in these terms
basically focusing on this interval and
its complement it's sufficient to induce
the correct distribution and that is
what yielded the double interval
structure that I claimed earlier
um sometimes I get asked the following
question so far you are assuming that
the state is one dimensional suppose
that you had a multinational State space
I haven't worked that out in this paper
um
if you were but here's a conjecture and
if you're interested in this I would
love to talk about it offline at the end
of this token so
um
in the in that multi-dimensional world
when the posterior mean is uh is is
a sufficient statistic I think what
would happen is that you would not have
obviously sub intervals of the state
space but perhaps you can think in terms
of the boxes or products of the sub
internal sort of State space use that to
Define
partitions and taking basically
differences of different boxes that you
associate with different signal
realizations one can induce a desired
posterior me so I think it suffices to
restrict the passion to that class of
practitional structures and I'm happy to
chat more about this if you're
interested
um one thing I forgot to mention here
and this is really about the
implications of the partitional
structure that pops up here is the
following under the optimal mechanism
what's going to happen is that the the
designer is going to activate some
agents to take action one for um some
low States and high States but not in
the middle that's a byproduct of the
double interval structure and that kind
of is a counterintuitive outcome right
you activate uu Perse some agents to
take action one in some low and high
States but not in the middle and that
really has to do with the fact that it
is not sufficient to restrict attach to
monotone partition structures and as
soon as you start focusing on these
ritual structures
um the intuitive monotonous properties
that you expect simply disappear
um Okay so
so I have I think nine minutes or so
left Yeah question
able structure and send signals
stochastically and
whether you could get a structure where
the the probability of buying more goes
is monotone in the state oh I see
um so I mean okay good so if you allow
for randomized mechanisms
right so basically you you're thinking
about
this sub internal just to make do it
more concrete I hit the sub interval and
then the probability of inducing uh one
chord to the smaller chord Tech action
one is decreasing as a function to say I
think you could Implement an optimal
that is this an Optimum mechanism that
that is that structure so I should
imagine that earlier throughout I'm
really thinking about um deterministic
mechanisms and as soon as you have that
restriction there's no way of getting
around
okay
yes so uh any comments
the private time probably signal okay
uh
[Music]
let's think about the social life
um I thought the question about would be
between public signal and the monotone
partitions versus the partition
structure that I allow for here then I
have an answer I think effective to be a
would be a bond but private versus
public I think you cannot create
instancespire to get is very large
uh what about settings that I don't know
the networks
think about what's going on here really
don't think that that matters is the
size of the course so suppose that
um I focus on the following class of
networks
um I have a I'm going to think about the
family of networks the ant family has
this degree sequence and I'm going to
have a uniform draw from set of all
networks it's consistent with this
degree sequence and the only requirement
I'm going to make is that the degrees
converge that is asymptotically a row K
fraction of the nodes will will have
degree k
pretty mild condition
well it turns out that and this is a
classical result it turns out that one
can actually characterize the um yes go
ahead
yes yes agents know the network designer
does not I'm comfortable with that
assumption because I have a supermodular
game so thinking about the best or the
worst equivalent that setting would be
the natural thing to do so the only
thing that would matter is the size of
the course and the designer may not know
that because the network information is
absent and the point is that for the
class of random networks that I just
described really characterizing the size
of the course boils down to solving a
simple system of equations if the degree
is finite this boils down to solving a
polynomial equation in particular and
that you can do the following let me use
a degree distribution to characterize
asymptotically about fractional nodes
will belong to the k core versus the K
Prime core let me write the optimization
problem the convex program that I wrote
earlier by replacing in the objective
the reward function the r case with the
fractions of the of the of the nodes in
one core or the other one and any
appropriate to be 18 and so on but
basically let me just think in terms of
the asymmetic fractions of nodes that
belong to one or the other chord
I could solve the same problem I could
still obtain a mechanism for this
limiting size of the course and it turns
out that you can show that
knowing just that limiting degrees and
therefore Computing the associated you
know fraction of modes that belong to
one or the other core versus using the
exact using the exact Network structure
the gap between the two is small the
payoff of the designer using the full
Network information is
um better but you know asymptotically
negligible way versus
um just knowing this limiting degree
distribution
in the network
play could you see could you probe these
random structures
[Music]
um so I okay I have not tried that so
basically you want to focus on not this
random graph photo but maybe a two type
model yeah yeah this result is very
interesting it's interesting what it is
about the predictability of the random
Grappler right
um
foreign
so far what did I do I told you about
how to obtain the optimal information
structure for a given Network I told you
about the random networks and
um I haven't told you about you know
what type of networks may lead to a
higher payoff for the designer versus
lower now I need to make some
assumptions otherwise this question is
ill post here's what I'm going to do
I'll focus on fixing the degrees of
nodes in the network and thinking about
wiring nodes in different ways and I'll
ask myself does one way of wiring the
nodes yield a higher pair for the
designer versus the other and I'll also
try to reason about the impact of the
degrees of the agents
but you know intuitively would expect
that having high if agents had higher
degrees the designer staff would be
larger because there are more metric
externalities turns out that that
intution is wrong and um I should say
not all this correct and I'll try to
explain why
so first let me just do the following
plot experiment I'm going to fix two
networks
um I'm going to focus on two Networks
um with the same degree sequence and
I'll think about the associated optimal
mechanisms Pi 1 and pi 2.
the only thing that's different between
these two networks is the way the edges
are wired okay so basically I'm asking
myself there are two networks the degree
the agents degrees are the same just the
wiring is different and designer uses
the optimal mechanism in both cases so I
get higher payoff in one network versus
other
well it turns out that if I wire High
degree agents to other high degree
agents so just taking it to the extreme
I'm thinking about the perfectly
assertive Networks
um neighbors of the degree the agent
also have the same degree d
it turns out that when I have this type
of wiring
the pair of the tie that the designer
can guarantee is going to be always
weekly higher than the payoff for any
other wire so really the perfect
assertivity here it enables the designer
to guarantee higher payoff
while the result is stated by focusing
on the perfect assertive yes
similar problem would be I pay people
out of a budget instead of
um persuading them
and on that front on this part it seems
like using similar results I'm trying to
figure out what's how much of this is
due to the actual persuasion structure
and how much it's due to having some
scarce resources here is basically a
higher posterior means shuffling around
beautiful players as opposed to money
I understand the question
um
so if I were to then let's ask a
different version of the problem we are
seeing let's say that I'm paying people
I have a budget and I'm allocating this
budget to to induce large number of
agents to take action one and I uh my
constraint is not the posteriorating
condition anymore it is it's the budget
constraint I still have the same object
would it be still the case that
um yeah it seems like you get a similar
kind of result here I would expect the
result to be similar just the intuition
here is that when
um DVD agency connects to other degree
agents other degree B agents basically
uh the amount that you need to pay to
activate all of them jointly
it's the same you do not end up you know
if you have a heterogeneous connection
structure and if you restrict attention
to public signals like it's uniform
payments in in your world you may end up
paying some agents more than the rest so
that you you you activate the
corresponding connected components then
you have the perfect assertivity you do
not have such inefficient allocations so
coming from this intuitive point of view
I would expect a similar conclusion to
hold in the transverse world as well
I think the answer is yes the only thing
that I'm really distant about is again
the um I'm focusing on public signals
here the correspondence between public
signals and the uniform payments in the
setting that you described it's not
exactly one-to-one but intuitively
things should move in the same direction
so I think that's a plus will conjecture
um even though I stated the results by
focusing on perfect assertive versus not
um at least in simulations the result
seems to hold in the interim regime as
well and I have one minute so I'll
conclude with this one
um here's what here's another thought
experiment I have two degree sequences
D1 and D2 and what I'm doing when I go
from D2 to D1 is to increase the degrees
of sum of the agents
so if you think about that I'm
increasing the aggregate Network
externality then what I do is to
uniformly draw One Network
from uh sorry actually first I'm asking
myself there are two these two networks
can I say that the designer has higher
payoff in one versus the other if the
connection structure is perfectly
assertive they are ranked in the way you
would expect them to be read when the
degrees of some agents are higher the
designers payoff is higher however the
thing that I find interesting is the
following suppose that I fixed the first
degree sequels and second one first one
dominates the second one in the first
one some agents have higher degree
um I fix these degree sequences then I
uniformly at random pick a network that
is consistent with this degree sequence
and I reason about the expected payoff
of the designer
well it turns out that it may change
non-monotonically here in this plot what
you what you have in the x-axis is the
parameters data is it increases I'm
basing basically increasing the degrees
of some of the low degree agents and
making them medium degree agents
even though I'm increasing the
um the the aggregate Network externality
the designers pay off changes
non-monotonically why is that happening
well basically as you increase the
degrees of the low degree agents and
make that Medium degree agents and then
start sampling networks uniform at
random some of the edges of the high
degree agents are now connected to
effectively lower degree agents so they
are no longer in large cores it becomes
harder to activate them
in terms of the cardinalities of the
course you see that clearly
um here the blue line is the line there
um
my parameter 0 is my parameter Zeta is
zero so um half of the ages are low half
of them are high degree when I make some
of the agents High uh higher degree or
medium degree what ends up happening is
that some of the agents are no longer in
the large course some of the high degree
agents are now connected to medium
degree nodes more frequently so it
becomes harder to activate them as a
result of that the pairs that you get
from high degree nodes goes down the
payoff from the low degree notes go up
but the net effect is indeterminate in
the slot what you see is that it may go
down first and up is a function of this
parameter that controls the uh the
domination of the degree distribution
so um that is that is really a byproduct
of the fact that you know the course
kind of this of the course changing
quite non-trivial ways as you start
um playing with them this is a slide
that I already discussed I'm going to
stop here thank you for your
affectionate questions
[Applause]
uh quick question so where did you use
the fact that you picked a sender
preferred equilibrium
uh in terms of in terms of the
structural properties I did not use it
that is a double interval structure
going back to earlier question does not
require that then I started playing with
um with um random networks and whatnot
really I had to focus on course because
I can you know and um correspondent
course I've been done in terms of the
standard preferred equations
of the course if I focus on the low
stick room that I'm not exactly sure
what to do
that was another question
yes uh you focus on the payoff of the
designer what about informativeness of
the optimal information structure can
you like Leverage your result to have a
competitive Statics on if I increase
some statistics of the network then the
informativeness of the optimal signal is
going to increase in the Blackwell sense
and it's easy because you have
partitions
okay so take the okay good I'm still
focusing on the optimal public mechanism
but I'm changing the network and the
question is is there any way that I
change a network that would increase the
informativeness oh yeah that's a
fantastic question I don't know the
answer
um yeah
I mean even though it's partitions
though I would say that's you know the
they're not exactly related in you know
black black refinement sense so no
indeed it would be a uh that strikes me
as a hard question but I think it's a
really good question
um
I think that kind of Rich the thing
where everyone can ask many different
questions and I think that I would be
interested in knowing the answer to that
one then you had a question as well
thank you so much
[Applause]
so we have a break to four